rappelez-vous fin juillet 2019 la
dernière clinique chirurgicale du centre
ville de Tours permet définitivement ses
blocs Saint-Gatien implantait juste en
face de la cathédrale déménager alors
son activité vers la clinique de
l'Alliance à Saint-Cyr-sur-Loire depuis
les 12000 mètres carrés de locaux ont
été murés en attente d'un projet clair
aujourd'hui on a cette un peu plus sur
l'avenir de ce site idéalement situé en
centre-ville Sarago
ainsi de 12000 mètres carrés au cœur de
la ville historique de Tours marquée par
Milan d'histoire de soins et d'accueil
un hospice au sixième siècle une
clinique en 1974 qui déménage en 2019
depuis le site était devenu un squat la
ville de Tours souhaitait lui redonner
un sens social mais aussi commercial qui
va y avoir un pôle social important qui
comprendra la maison de l'hospitalité
mais également une pension de famille on
accueillera des bureaux des commerces
une école supérieure un restaurant et
puis avec l'idée de créer un rooft que
tous les tours un jour et tout ranger
attend des souhaits de leurs vœux
un futur rooftop ouvert à tous avec une
vue imprenable sur la cathédrale et les
toits du vieux tour
pour l'heure le lieu accueille pendant 9
mois la clinique du street art une
exposition temporaire dans le noir qui
concentre 1500 mètres carrés de graffiti
ils ont été réalisés en 5 jours sous
l'oeil de Bob je dis spécialiste du
street art qui est allé dénicher 30
artistes de tout âge
2023 c'est les 60 ans de l'art urbain en
France j'ai découpé bien sûr le les 60
ans en trois générations puisque ces
trois générations la quatrième arrivée
en maintenant d'artistes le doyen et
c'est Gérard zoetic Amiens donc il y a
83 ans qui est venu ici et puis la plus
jeune c'est et de Tours et à 23 ans des
visites payantes à la lampe torche sont
organisées pour voir les fresques elles
seront ensuite détruites pour laisser
place aux travaux